[Music]
bmp manufacturing facility is located
we have subsidiaries in 28 countries and
distribute to an additional of 73
countries and currently we employ over
3000 employees worldwide
our mission is to serve the needs in
life science research and to translate
new scientific findings into clinical
applications
as for the agenda
first we will have a brief look at the
biology and function of t cells as well
as on the concept of workflows
next we will highlight our mux
technology and why it is the best for
cell separation
after that
welcome to the main part of this
presentation the t-cell separation
product highlights
finally we will have a short summary
including a brief presentation of our
highlight diesel workflows
let's begin with the biology and
function of t cells as well as with the
concept of proclose
well when talking about t-cell
phenotypes and function mostly surface
markers cytokines and transcription
factors come into play
accordingly these will be most talked
about when it comes to teaser separation
culture and analysis
t-cells play as the factors of the
immune system an integral role in the
adaptive immunity
they can be roughly subdivided into
several phenotypically and functionally
distinct subsets such as t helper cells
cytotoxic t killer cells t regulatory
cells as well as the rather heterogenic
group of unconventional t-cells
comprising for example natural killer
t-cells and gamma-delta t-cells
t-cells are the only immune cells that
are able to form a long-lasting
immunological memory that helps to
respond faster and more efficient to
already experience threats
key surface markers that are always
mentioned in regards to t-cells are the
t-cell receptor tcr that recognize
antigens as well as the activating core
receptors cd3 and cd28
those three surface markers are present
on all t cells
furthermore co receptors cd4 and cd8 are
the defining markers for key helper
cells and cytotoxic key killer cells
respectively
to exert their function as the factors
of the immune system t-cells release
cytokines to communicate with the
environment and to cause various effects
such as promoting inflammation
these include interlocking two
interleukin-4 interferon gamma 2 and
across the factor alpha transforming
growth factor beta and interlocking 10.
these threads are most relevant in those
maintenance of health as well as
fighting diseases
last but not least these properties make
t-cells ideal tools for immunotherapy
where t-cells for example are
genetically modified as car t-cells to
attack concepts specifically
although our based on products are of
course the microbeads of isolation kits
we are not just a cell separation
company we actually cover the whole
experimental diesel workflow from cell
separation to cellular analysis
including also sample preparation as
well as cell culture
we provide thereby solutions for each
step of your experiment
today however in the first part of our
t-cell webinar series we will indeed
talk about t-cell separation including
microbeads isolation kits and of course
automation
t-cell culture and diesel analysis
webinars will follow soon
we thought maybe the best way to arrange
our quite large diesel portfolio are
distinct workflows
specifically designed for your
experimental needs
thereby we cover as focused workflows
amongst others regulatory t cells car
tesla research gamma delta t cells tumor
infiltrating leukocytes polarization of
t cells antigen virus specific key cells
and of course activation and expansion
of t-sets
with these comprehensive workflows you
can easily choose the product relevant
for your specific field of interest
please note that our tesol portfolio is
growing by the day and their respective
workflows are all constantly evolving so
click regularity for updates
by the way you may notice throughout the
presentation small yellow buttons paired
with a little click hang symbol just the
one here like the one here on the lower
right in the pdf version of this talk
you can access the respective product
pages marketing materials videos and
protocols by simply clicking these
buttons as there are all hyperlinked
well getting your whole workflow from
milton biotech means ease of mind
standardization reputability and
organization of an experimental workflow
become much more feasible
miltoni a supplier for the whole tc
workflow means that all reagents fulfill
the same high quality criteria and the
order process can be streamlined
thereby harmonizing the steps of an
experiment as well as automation and
upscaling are easily performed
getting all products with any guarantees
smooth procedures and less errors since
for example our cell separation is
tested for compatibility with our flow
cytometry and our media we for
compatibility with our cytokines and so
forth
moreover evan milkeny a full supplier
for the whole workflow means also
getting full support for every step of
your experiment thanks to our great
scientific support team
moreover a hallmark feature of milton's
workflow solutions is the seamless
translation from a research setting into
a clinical setting and back
thanks to our max gmt portfolio as well
as cell manufacturing platforms such as
the clini max prodigy
well let's go to the next part of this
presentation why max technology is the
best to isolate ut cells
cell separation poses many challenges to
the researcher
high purity and repair
recovery are of course important but
also is reproducibility cell viability
and compatibility to downstream
applications
furthermore there is a variety of
different tifa subtypes that might be of
interest and have to be separated
individually
some of them display very low
frequencies in the variety of different
starting materials and are really hard
to obtain and of course cell separation
should be fast and easy to use
consequently there are many cell
separation challenges to face and gladly
miltoni biotech offers the right
solution for all of them
but why use miltoni biotech for cell
enrichment and what does max technology
make so special
well in short it's our select the best
approach
minimum labeling with no effects on cell
biology for full downstream
compatibility
in more detail
our max columns are a technological
advantage as the column amplifies the
magnetic field by 10 000 volts
this allows for minimal labeling and
smaller speed size of only around 50
nanometers
in consequence less epitopes are covered
on the side surface and less strength is
applied on the cells
so as thousands of publications prove
the isolated t-cells are fully suited
for any downstream application including
flow analysis
thereby max microbeads were even
approved by the fda to be used in a
specific clinical setting
it is important to note that the column
allows for the most gentle
sorting since there is a large space
between the steel spheres of the column
matrix
with about 20 times the size of
electrocytes
the t-cells will pass through smoothly
without any negative effects as you can
see here this is a small lymphocyte and
there's really more than enough space
between the stem spheres in the column
have a look at the data on the right
side with the 3d 3 labeled t cells
column 3 technology results in beet
aggregates in culture as well as in a
clocked cell surface with max column
technology you see no beat aggregation
culture and many minimum labeling of
fully functional cells
and indeed you see also in these western
worlds that t-cells are not activated
after cell isolation with max technology
cd4 positive key sets were isolated with
either positive selection or negative
selection using max technology or a
column-free competitor method
the activation status was then assessed
by
analyzing the different isolated t-cell
samples and performing a western blot
from mud kinase phosphorylation which is
a reliable marker
for t-cell activation status
on the left side
you see a western block for p-38
phosphorization after positive isolation
of cd4 positive t cells using either cd4
milton microbeads
human or two column free
competitors
untreated and sds trees that supt-1
cells served as negative and positive
control respectively
it can be clearly seen that
self-isolated just max technology yields
a much lower phosphor p38 expression
than cells isolate with the competitor
technology
on the right side
you see a western blocker junk 1 and 2
phosphorylation
after negative isolation of cd4 positive
t-cells using either maintenance cd4 t
cell isolation kit human or
three competitor
column free systems
also here untreated and lps treated
supt-1 cells served as negative and
positive control respectively
again it can be clearly seen that cells
isolated with max technology yield a
much lower phospho-junk kinase 1 and 2
expression than the cells isolated with
the competitor technology
both western blocks clearly show that
cell separation with max technology is
the most gentle
and does not activate pieces regardless
of positive or negative selection
yeah talking about positive or negative
selection generally max cell separation
technology offers two different
separation strategies
first positive selection with our micro
beams and micro beam
target cells are hereby labeled and
directly selected via the specific and
defining marker
as target cells are still magnetically
labeled afterwards they are usually not
suited for an additional round of sub
separation except when you use rear leaf
microbeads where the label can be
removed via an additional step we will
come later to this exciting technology
the positive selection approach with
microbeads is very specific and ideally
suited for rare cells or undefined
signal cell suspensions such as tumor as
well as other difficult or compromised
samples for example from sick donors
also isolation directly from whole blood
and blood products is very well achieved
with max positive selection
secondly
we have the untouched isolation with our
isolation kits
working via the depletion of non-target
cells
this is necessary when a target cell
fraction is not defined by a certain
marker but rather the length zero
hereby all cells expressing a defined
exclusion marker cocktail are depleted
and the target sets remain unlabeled and
thus are usable for further rounds of
sub separation
however in work in order to work
efficiently the single cell suspension
has to be rather well defined as it is
the case with for example human pvmcs or
mouse spleen single cell suspensions
taken together different isolation
strategies
allow to get the most out of your sample
with miltoni being an expert in all cell
separation strategies playing with and
combining the different approaches
offers a great flexibility according to
your needs
and is the secret to success
consequently maxwell separation
technology comes with four different
approaches to perfectly reflect the
different starting materials
first we have microbeads and microwave
kits that are ideal for positive diesel
separation from pbmcs and various tissue
signal cell suspensions
they also include the new rear lease
technology for label-free positive cell
separation
separation of basic t-cells and almost
any t-cell subtypes from different
species like human mouse red and
non-human climate make microbeads and
microbead kits a very versatile cell
separation approach
second
and almost equally versatile we have the
isolation kits that are ideal for all
untouched separation needs
the used starting materials are pbmcs or
defined single cell suspensions
also the isolation kits cover basic
t-cells as well as almost any t-cell
subtype from different species like
human mouse red and non-human private
however
if you do not want to get over a density
graded to your pvmcs
as a starting material you can now
isolate t cells also fast and directly
from whole blood and blood products
so as a third option we have our
straight from micro bit kits for the
isolation of human cd3 cd4 and cd8 t
cells directly from whole blood and
blood products without the need for
density gradient it is a reliable way to
get your t-cells fast and easy
and is of course fully automatable
and for the separation variant we offer
much expressive isolation kits
also here human t-rex and t cells as
well as cd4 and cd8 subsets and even cd4
memory t-cells can be isolated directly
from all black blood products without
the need for density gradient this time
however it is an untouched cell
isolation approach max express is the
fastest and most uncomfortable
complicated manual cell separation
approach
one of the many things that sets miltoni
biotech teacher portfolio apart is its
broadness and diversity
we cover more than just the basic human
mouse these are subjects
indeed over 90 t-cell separation
products cover virtually every thesis
subject addressing these researchers
needs worldwide
for example different naive and
memorabilia subtypes as well as the
health cell subsides are covered
furthermore different key regulatory
cells gamma delta t cells and nkt cell
separation kits are available as well as
complete workforce for antigen-specific
t-cells cytokines equity teachers and
card teaser research and so many more
apart from human and mouse samples we
offer also t-cell separation kits for
red and non-human primary samples
as scientists we understand how
important it is to address the full
complexity of t-cell subtypes even for
the rare ones and to offer according
solutions in the following slides i will
give an overview of the most important
teaser separation products including our
highlights
so let's go to the main part of this
presentation our diesel highlight
products
the first highlights
of search separation products in the key
cell area are our t-cell isolation kits
for the untouched isolation of various
human and mouse design subjects
of course tickets offer our well-known
high purity in recovery
however
also a very important factor is of
course the protocol speed especially
with untouched isolation faster protocol
times are flavored
methane biotech offers therefore a total
of 17 fast cell isolation kits that
allow to isolate publication quality
target cells in only 18 minutes
the six mouse fast isolation kits
comprise the most important tc subsets
as well as two piecer kits the 11 human
fast isolation kits also cover the most
important t-cell subsets as well as
b-cells nk cells and monocytes
so instead of long active processing we
offer a fast easy protocol
however it doesn't stop here with the
isolation kits
also our best-selling mouse microphones
were improved and the protocols updated
by reducing tedious washing steps and
optimizing incubation types
in three easy steps preparation labeling
and separation you get from speed to
target cells in less than 15 minutes so
it's simply straightforward
cd4 positive mcd8 positive mouse t cells
as well as
cd90.1 mouse and rex t cells and also cd
90.2 mouse t cells can now be isolated
by a positive selection only 30.5
minutes using our updated microwaves
mouse
of course
with the ever appreciated quality and
purity
it is an easy and fast protocol that can
be fully automated on the auto max pro
or the multi-max
each micro bit kit has a high capacity
of 2 times 10 to the 9 total cells which
corresponds to up to 20 mouse speeds
consequently with their high sample
capacity and automation options the
updated micro beats mouse are not only
economic but also very efficient and
therefore ideally suited for the
processing of high sample numbers
and again it doesn't matter if you use
positive or negative selection cell
separation with max technology is fully
downstream compatible and has no effects
on the cell biology in either case
in this example t cells were either
positively selected with cd4 cd8
microbeads mouse or isolated untouched
with our own respective
diesel isolation kits which are the gold
standards
directly after isolation
here in able to stay zero and after one
day of cultivation with and without
stimulus using the t-cell activation in
expansion kit marked with plus
and minus respectively activation
markers cd25 and cigna69 were analyzed
by flow cytometry to assess a potential
activation
as you can see without
stimulation cells are neither activated
and separated positively
nor when separated negatively
um
with microbeads or isolation kits
respectively
this means that both cell isolation
methods are equally gentle
when stimulated on purpose
with the t-cell activation expansion
kits cells are highly activated and
upregulate accordingly cd25 and cd69
regardless of the isolation strategy
meaning that both isolation methods are
equally suited for functional downstream
application this is due to for both cd4
and cd8 cells as here shown in this
example
consequently both approaches do not
affect cell biology and ensure full tcl
functionality while ensuring fast and
gentle isolation
as a useful tip
which you see here in the box on the
lower right and these boxes are
at several points in this presentation
and we would like to suggest to not use
red blood cell lyses because this indeed
activates your t cell
before the isolation
however the red blood cell lyse is not
needed for digital isolation with our
max microbeads from mouse b
so better avoid it completely
our next highlight products are the
straight from microbeads straight from
microbeads allow the isolation of target
cells directly from blood and blood
products without density gradient
centrifugation
in regards to these t cells cd3 positive
cd4 positive and cd8 positive
supplements are covered and can be
directly isolated from whole blood
particles gluco-reduction system
chambers also called lrscs and nucopax
of course cell separation is straight
from is automatable depending on the
starting material this means processing
on either automatic pro or multi-max are
possible and reduces processing time for
example of a button code to only 30
minutes
indeed protocols need to be far easy
especially for larger screening purposes
automized and high throughput options
may be desirable
furthermore starting materials in the
case of flat products come in different
formats and the restriction here is not
desirable
moreover
sometimes samples and cell numbers are
limited
so of course cell loss especially when
working with small or rare samples must
be minimized and purity maximized
however most importantly cells must not
be activated by the isolation to ensure
that for example really only the
specifically stimulated t cells
proliferate and are fully functional
straight from is here the ideal solution
a fast and flexible positive isolation
approach that allows to isolate
different cell types from the same
sample with minimal loss due to the
skipping of density gradient
centrifugation
this makes straightforward technology
also ideal for the isolation of t-cells
for example in the field of car t-cell
research
to date
the most widely used method to isolate
target cells from whole blood and blood
products is however performing identity
grade intensification for the generation
of pbmcs followed then by cell
separation of targets and subtypes
apart from the time consumer protocol is
over two hours processing time the
handling is rather complicated and does
not allow for automation
furthermore a significant amount of
target sets may be easily lost in a user
dependent fashion
in addition harsh and long handling as
well as some gradient media may affect
the cells at least to some degree so act
carefully
the alternative to that is
gradient centrifugation is maintenance
straight from technology hereby cells
can be directly isolated from blood
products in a fast and easy way without
dense degrading certification cell
counting or washing the procedure is
fast subjective and can be fully
automated so from samples of target
cells in only 30 minutes fast easy and
convenient
this is of course also backed up by flow
cytometry data and the assessment of
activation market expression
after isolation
in this example cd4 positive and cd8
positive t cells were isolated from
bicycles either with straight from cd4
cd8 microbeads
on the left side
or via density gradient
centrifugation to get the bbmcs followed
by a competitor's untouched particular
isolation like here on the right side
cells were then activated for activation
marker expression of 60 25 cd69 either
directly after cell isolation here
labeled with the day zero
or after one or two days of cultivation
either without stimulus or stimulated
with the diesel activation
and expansion
labeled with
minus
or plus respectively
cells isolatedly straight from show
almost no activation marker expression
even after that two days of culture
however when activated
on purpose
using the t-cell activation and
expansion kits the cells highly
upregulate cd25 and cd69
showing their full biological
functionality
cells that were isolated by identity
gradient
centrifugation followed by a
competitor's untouched palm diesel
isolation
instead showed a higher activation
marker expression from the beginning on
directly after isolation and one or two
days later and consequently may not be
efficiently activated in downstream
applications such as polio global or
antigen specific activation
our next key cell separation highlights
are the real these
microgridscapes
this revolutionary microbead technology
allows to positively select cells
but then remove the microbit and the
antibody labeling to get completely
label-free sets
release microwave kits are available for
human and mouse t-cell and non-t-cell
subtypes including markers such as csv
cd4 cd8 cd90 cd25 cd56 cd62l cd 90.1 and
2 cd 279 also called pt1 and tc arcana
delta
this offers researchers an extremely
entirely new level of flexibility and
new separation strategies combining the
best of two words
highly specific positive selection and
if needed label free for example for
further subset separations
the procedure itself is very easy after
cell separation there is a beat removal
step with the beat release reagent cells
are now ready for a second round of
magnetic labeling
and an additional optional step can then
be applied using the release reagent to
also remove the bound antibodies it
complex from the cell surface thus to
obtain completely labor-free cells and
make all epitopes accessible again
however the advantages of real yeast do
not end here realist is so gentle and
minimally invasive due to the special
structure of the release
that even cell isolation via cd3 does
not activate
the thesis regardless of the labor
removal
as you can see in the example here of
isolated human cd sweep positive key
cells on the left side
activation marker cd69 is not
upregulated amongst pre-gated cd4
positive t cells
neither after cd3 labeling nor after
isolation nor after label release
however when activating cells on purpose
cd69 is nicely upregulated
and shows the biological function of the
t cells
please note that pregating on cd8
positive tests that showed exactly the
same results
the example on the right side however
shows a multi-step subset isolation with
shoulder using vms
first cd4 positive t cells are
pre-selected then the label is removed
and cells are now ready for a second
round of deeper subset separation in
this case via cd25
for t-rex isolation
with that you can actually get your
t-rex on from almost every single cell
suspension
further examples that are similar
include
for example the isolation of gamma delta
t cells as well as cd3 negative nk cells
another fantastic and very specialized
cell separation product are the till
microbeads
the microbeads have a special
formulation to facilitate the isolation
of tumor infiltrating leukocytes
abbreviated tills from tumor signal cell
suspensions
tails are very rare cells and the tuber
tissue is a heterogenic and hard to
process starting material
this poses quite a challenge to the
researcher and successful isolation of
tilts
in this context the specialized teal
microbeads are the ideal tool to
efficiently enrich viable and pure tilts
from tumor single cell suspensions with
highest recovery rates
the tin microbeads are available for
human and mouse cd45 cd3 cd4 and cd8
construct cells
the human team aggregates are moreover
available as realist version to
facilitate label-free isolation of
target cells from human tumor tissue
the till microbeads are best integrated
in our wholesome and comprehensive till
workflow
so ideally combine our tail isolation
solutions with our dedicated sample
preparation solutions pro portfolio and
imaging portfolio for best results
please have also a look at the
respective applications and product
pages as well as the webinars by
following here the links on the right
side
finally
i want to point out a cell separation
product that is absolutely unique
the cytokine secretion essays
they allow to detect and enrich viable
cytokine secreting cells from mouse and
human samples
thereby cytokines are immobilized on the
surface of the security cell by the
so-called catch reagent basically
thereby the cell labels itself with its
own cytokines
in a second step the immobilized
cytokines are then labeled with
fluorophore conjugated antibodies called
detector measures and can then be
detected viably without intracellular
staining on any flow cytometer
in an optional third step the
fluorophore-labeled cytokine secreting
cells can be specifically enriched and
used in downstream animals by using
antifluorophore magnetic beads
consequently our cytokine secretion
essays come in two versions
for flow detection only we have the
detection kits
for the separation of viable cytokinesic
readings the secreting set we have the
detection app enrichment kits including
the additional enrichment step via a max
column
max technology offers depending on the
researchers needs
different manual and automated cell
separation options for upscaling
manual separation with the quattro or
octo max for up to four or eight samples
in parallel respectively
automated options include the automatic
pro for full walk away convenience for
occupied centers
the multi-max cell 24 separator plus for
the processing of up to 24 samples in
parallel
and finally the multi-max x for flexible
fully automated high throughput
industrial applications with any source
material
now every researcher can reliably
automate cell separation for more
efficient workflows and higher
consistency
of course
all the automated options are applicable
to most of our tc separation solutions
finally we can start to sum up this talk
and briefly present some of our key
t-cell workflows
as mentioned before the variety of our
tsa products is best organized in
comprehensive workflows following your
scientific interest
consequently please find here listed our
highlight application workflows with
clickable links
to the respective application and
protocol pages as well as to further
info material and webinars
of course there are more and our
selection is growing by the day
however our highlights include
polarization of t cells with protocols
and cytokine combinations for the most
efficient polarization of your cd4
positive key helper sets
the regulatory t cell workflow with all
needed solutions for the isolation as
well as the expansion and analysis of
rare t-rex in a translational setting
the car tesla research workflow covering
all steps from key cell isolation to
activation to transduction and finally
car key potency analysis for fully
translational and functional generation
of car pieces in a research or small
scale setting
the till workflow to efficiently
dissociate tumor tissue and isolate even
the rarest two infiltrating nucleoside
the antigen-specific t-cell workflow
optimized for the specific stimulation
of antigen-reactive t-cells as well as
the isolation analysis analysis of these
extremely rare cells in different
contexts
and finally a copic 90 virus-specific
keys workflow that covers each step from
stimulation to enrichment to analyze
analysis of starscope 2 reactive t-cells
have a look at their respective
application pages and webinars to find
out more
although
our teaser portfolio is quite extensive
as you can see here in the full teaser
workflow overview you have to remember
just three easy things
we offer the best teaser separation
but
we cover also the whole tc workflow
and finally we have a solution for every
pain point
so have all the success with our
innovative and complete key cell
portfolio as displayed here in this
school featured overview our teaser
portfolio is growing by the day the
respective workflow or views are
constantly evolving so check regular
library for updates
please follow also the links on the
lower right to access the respective
teaser product pages as well as to
download our tc brochures
talking about more information of course
you can find a variety of helpful
marketing material downloadable from our
web page www
for teaser-specific applications
just click on the button on the lower
right side
the information includes flyers and
brochures davina's videos protocols data
sheets customer reports application
nodes scientific posters
and data sets
and of course you can always directly
reach out to the responsible sales
respect representative in your area
i hereby end this presentation with this
nice picture of our company campus in
turkish club
thank you very much for your attention
you